Is there anything that
you would want to say
about Algorand, about what
you guys are working on,
to the audience while
we have the time?
The tech is there.
Come build with us.
We would be thrilled
to work with you.
And also, ask hard questions
about whether your blockchain
is quantum resistant. Very important.
What are some words
of wisdom that
have helped you maneuver
through some of the
trials of life
that might help somebody
that's watching this today?
Trying to do the
right thing for
the right reasons.
You have to ask
some very fundamental questions.
And if what you're
doing doesn't have crisp,
clear answers, like
fundamental questions about, like,
is this the right
thing to do?
Do the right thing.
So important.